bonjour à tous on va débuter avec
l'agenda aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy et
en tunisie il est accompagné d'eric
ciotti de rachida dati de christophe
andré frassa christian jacob
alain joyandet pierre lellouche et
renaud muselier
à l'occasion de ce déplacement le
président rencontrera le président
tunisie monsieur s epci dont qui est
quand même le président du seul pays qui
a entamé une transition démocratique et
qui se bat contre contre l'islamisme en
tunisie qui a fait de nombreux morts
récemment
11h45 il y aura un dépôt de gerbe à la
mémoire des victimes des attaques
terroristes au du musée du bardo puis un
déjeuner en présence de plusieurs
membres du gouvernement tunisien dont
monsieur najeeb garzon ministre de
l'intérieur le ministre des finances le
ministre de l'éducation et le ministre
de la santé également à 18 heures il y
aura une réunion publique conjointe
entre les républicains et le parti nida
tounes qui aura lieu à l'hôtel la
résidence
voilà donc nous allons maintenant passer
au sujet de l'europe et nous allons
rebondir aux propositions de françois
hollande sur la tribune qui a eu qui a
été publié dans le jdd donc je vais
passer la parole à à roger karoutchi
qu'un pour deux
que dire d'une tribune dont l'écho
restera confidentiel quand on ne sait
plus ce qu'il faut faire quand il ya
plus de volonté politique ont créé une
institution
chacun sait que on a un vrai problème de
renforcement des pouvoirs du parlement
européen
chacun sait que on a un vrai problème de
gestion de la gouvernance économique
commission européenne parlement européen
conseil européen qu'est ce qu'apporte la
proposition du chef de l'état de
création d'un parlement de l'euro
strictement rien existe déjà leur groupe
qui a pris un certain nombre de
décisions d'ailleurs il faut pas non
plus réduire la compétence ou les
pouvoirs de leurs euros
mais franchement quel est l'intérêt de
la création d'un parlement de l'euro ça
n'a pas d'intérêt
c'est pas un parlement qui va gérer
l'euro enfin on imagine bien que un
parlement n'est pas là pour gérer une
monnaie ça n'a pas de sens alors qu'on
nous explique que au sein de l'europe il
faille séparer sans des équipes ou des
pays plus en avant appelons ça avant
garde
dans le passé on a appelé ça qu'on les
secteurs concentriques
mais en réalité la crise de l'europe
elle est dans la crise de leadership de
l'accent calment elle est dans la remise
en cause de ce leadership par la volonté
de l'allemagne qui ne comprend pas bien
qui ne comprend plus la politique
française soit de se rapprocher du
royaume uni soit d'avoir une politique
par rapport à l'europe de l'est et à la
russie
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de crise
d'institutions en europe la création
d'une institution supplémentaire est
totalement inutile
il ya une crise de leadership et chris
de volonté politique et à la crise de
l'axé franco-allemand qui dans le passé
a réalisé des principales avancées et
qui aujourd'hui
plus la réalité de la vie européenne et
ce qui s'est passé pour la grèce c'est
une évolution
j'allais presque dire sous la contrainte
dans la difficulté avec une action forte
de l'eurogroupe une action forte
également du conseil européen mais en
même temps malheureusement et depuis le
début il n'y a pas eu une position
unifiée d'un axe franco allemand qui
aurait pris le leadership sur l'ensemble
que l'on nous dise françois hollande a
joué un rôle a contraint pas contraint
guélat merkel c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne l'axé franco-allemand si on
veut un axe franco allemand fort c'est
une définition commune d'une politique
dès le départ et ensuite le fait
d'entraîner l'europe dans cette
politique c'est pas des règlements nuit
dans la nuit
kiki qui font la franco allemand donc
nous sommes opposés à la création d'un
parlement de l'euro qui n'a aucun sens
nous disons seulement il faut faire
fonctionner au mieux les institutions
européennes
retrouvez la réalité d'une volonté d'un
volontarisme politique de l' axe
franco-allemand et à partir de là
refaire une dynamique européenne mais
c'est pas parce que vous êtes en crise
qu'il faut créer des institutions
supplémentaires ça ne sert strictement à
rien qu'une méthode socialiste seulement
étonnante on n'a pas de solution donc on
va créer un colloque d'une institution
un groupe de travail donc ça suffit
il n'y a pas besoin de parlement de
l'euro une bonne gestion de l'euro par
l'eurogroupe d'un parlement européen qui
agissent d'une commission européenne qui
agissent et d'un axe franco-allemand qui
reprennent l'initiative
c'est là qu'elle socialistes ont le chic
pour créer des comités théodule en
france maintenant il voudrait en crée
autant au niveau européen ce n'est qu'un
écran de fumée pour masquer les
difficultés qu'à eues françois hollande
et les crispations qui a eu dans le
couple franco allemand
on va passer au projet de loi sur le
droit des étrangers qui qui est présenté
à l'assemblée nationale donc déjà
l'intitulé de ce projet de loi nous nous
interroge c'est droit des étrangers
c'est encore augmenter les droits des
étrangers cela nous semble assez
dangereux et irresponsable dans le
contexte
actuel puisque nous avons une crise des
migrants nous avons une crise de
schengen on a un chômage qui est
absolument fou en france et que nous ne
parvenons pas à endiguer malgré le
traitement social de celui-ci par par le
gouvernement et puis un communautarisme
galopant qui symbolise une crise de
l'intégration donc nous nous pensons que
ce que ce projet de loi est assez
dangereux qu'il crée les conditions d'un
nouvel appel d'air sans précédent pour
l'immigration à un moment où la france
n'a plus les moyens d'accueillir de
nouveaux de nouveaux immigrants et à un
moment où il ya plus de 8 millions de
français qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté donc c'est un c'est un mauvais
signal
par ailleurs c'est encore une fois une
façon de donner davantage de droits
notamment de droits sociaux avec cette
carte de santé pour pour les étrangers
alors que là et me a triplé de 300
millions est passé à un coût d'un
milliard pour et cela est financé par
quand même le contribuable français
donc c'est assez dangereux sur le point
des dix mille titres de séjour que l'on
accorderait aux talents et aux cerveaux
étrangers
moi j'ai quelques doutes
puisqu'aujourd'hui les talents et les
cerveaux français sont condamnés à
l'exil de très nombreux jeunes diplômés
sont condamnés à quitter la france pour
pouvoir trouver un travail et avoir une
perspective d'avenir donc retenons déjà
ses cerveaux la retenons déjà ses
talents là au front lors des
perspectives d'avenir
un véritable travail des moyens
notamment pour pour les chercheurs avant
d'aller accueillir d'autres d'autres
talents et on en a ici en france dans
nos universités dans nos écoles
et puis aberration absolue de ce projet
de loi c l'assignation à résidence
quelque sorte on marche sur la tête
puisque face à des personnes qui sont en
situation irrégulière le gouvernement de
me mettre fin au centre de rétention
pour les assignats réalise art
y danse dans des personnes qui sont en
situation régulière mais qui ont une
résidence déclaré c'est assez c'est
assez étrange je pense qu'en définitive
c'est quand même un feu vert pour les
trafiquants et les passeurs et c'est
leur dire venez en france tous les
droits seront seront ouverts vous aurez
des droits est absolument aucun devoir
et aucune contrepartie vous vous sera
demandé oui alors le texte qui arrive
droit des étrangers
moi je le dis franchement c'est pas un
scandale mais pas loin lorsqu'il ya eu
le texte sur le droit d'asile
le gouvernement s'était engagé à nous
dire sur un deuxième texte sur
l'immigration
je dis bien sur l'immigration pas sur le
droit des étrangers et on nous a demandé
au parlement de ne pas évoquer notamment
leur accompagnement aux frontières pour
l'ensemble des immigrés en situation
irrégulière en nous affirmant que
naturellement cette partie là essentiel
quand même dans le dispositif serait
dans le texte immigration
finalement le texte droit d'asile est
devenu un texte fonio franc symbolique
et qui ne règle en rien les problèmes de
droit d'asile parce que d'un côté on a
dit on accélère les procédures et comme
d'un autre côté on a accru
considérablement les capacités de
recours
en réalité on n'a rien à accélérer du
tout il ya donc toujours 65 mille
demandeurs d'asile il ya toujours
seulement 15000 personnes qui vont être
acceptée et sur les 50 milles restant
bahia nadim il raccompagnait aux
frontières et 40000 qui deviennent des
clandestins c'est à dire que la
république continue chaque année de
fabriquer elle même
quarante mille clandestins au travers de
la dérive du droit d'asile
on attendait ce texte immigration avec
intérêt pourquoi parce que chacun est
bien conscient qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
rupture dans l' équilibre de la société
française nous sommes à un niveau où
aujourd'hui il ya une acceptation plus
difficile parce que comme l'a si bien
dit lidia
naturellement le chômage qui s'accroît
les difficultés de vie qui s'accroissent
le départ de nos jeunes etc finissent
par créer un sentiment de doute sur ce
qu'est la nation ce qu'est la république
ce qu'est l'état et par conséquent c'est
pas dans cette période là qu'il faut
donner le sentiment que nous ne
maîtrisons pas l'immigration régulière
et donc nous avons un texte sur le droit
des étrangers
il n'y a rien dedans sur la maîtrise
rien c'est effectivement des cartes sur
la santé le fait de pouvoir accéder plus
facilement un certain nombre de services
administratifs
le fait de ne plus avoir à passer par un
certain de sas d'ailleurs on se dit est
ce que le gouvernement est conscient de
la réalité de la situation de la france
est ce que réellement on peut continuer
d'avoir un regroupement familial de
cette importance est ce qu'on peut
continuer d'avoir une entrée aussi
massif sur le territoire national alors
que d'autres pays ont mis en place des
quotas ont mis en place un certain
nombre de mesures pour n'avoir que
l'immigration choisie non pas
l'immigration suis donc c'est dommage
c'est une chance supplémentaire avec ce
texte eux raté d'avoir de vraies mesures
nous ferons guillaume larrivé le fait
pour l'assemblée nous ferons au sénat et
nous ferons ici même une journée de
travail au mois de septembre avant que
le texte ne revienne au sénat sur
l'immigration et nous ferons des
propositions sur la baisse du niveau de
l'immigration régulière
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faudra que l'on
se mette bien d'accord sur les moyens
financiers supplémentaires donnés sur le
accompagnement aux frontières toute
cette politique n'a pas de sens si on ne
donne pas les moyens à la police et à la
gendarmerie de raccompagner aux
frontières de la même manière nous
ferons des propositions sur la
réglementation le fait que les
directives européennes ne soient pas
maxima mais a minima
si l'on veut maîtriser l'immigration et
on posera la question clairement au
gouvernement qui la tue quand même
positions variables sur qu'est ce qui se
passe avec les discussions au niveau
européen sur entre
i mais la répartition des migrants
arrivés en italie un cours nous dit que
le gouvernement français refuse les
quotas un coup on nous dit qu'il a
accepté un quota 10000 sur les deux
années à venir
un coup on nous dit que 10000 c'est une
première tranche va quand même falloir
nous dire exactement ce qui se passe
c'est une évidence qu'il faut revenir
sur schengen qui faut un schengen 2
qu'il faut on le voit bien avec six
passes en méditerranée la situation
n'est pas tenable
il faut faire ça de manière humaine mais
en même temps nous n'avons plus ni les
moyens lydia le disais à l'instant la
hem explose
le gouvernement refuse de réduire la m e
à l'aide humanitaire et accepte
l'ouverture complète ce n'est plus
possible
on le voit bien et je passe sur un
phénomène qui suppliait subit encore par
nos hôpitaux avec ce que vous avez pu
voir récemment c'est-à-dire la dette de
120 millions d'euros d'étrangers qui
viennent se faire soigner en france qui
repartent qu'ils payent pas donc un
moment un peu de maîtrise et de la
dépense et des flux une baisse du niveau
des rentrées une augmentation des
raccompagnements
si l'on veut que les immigrés en
situation régulière
je dis bien en situation régulière
puissent s'intégrer réussir leur
intégration en france
il faut évidemment en parallèle une
politique de fermeté qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
alors nous allons maintenant venir au
sujet de la crise des éleveurs
donc nous sommes face un gouvernement
qui ne fait que des propositions qui
sont conjoncturelles comme avec ses 23
millions qui ont été débloqués pour
baisser les charges des éleveurs et des
à leur trésorerie 23 millions c'est pas
d'où d'où sort ce chiffre on ne sait pas
où ça a été donc c'est vraiment c'est
des mesures qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux c'est comme mettre un
sparadrap sur sur une jambe de bois
on a l'impression que la gauche méprise
le monde rural et les éleveurs les
agriculteurs puisque même le ministre de
l'agriculture n'est qu'un ministre à mi
temps et passe beaucoup plus de temps à
être porte-parole du gouvernement qu'à
être ministre de l'agriculture
les éleveurs l'attendent à quand ils le
souhaitent les recevoir que jeudi à
paris voilà donc on pense que c'est un
véritable une véritable difficulté qui a
quelques mesures qui peuvent être mises
en place afin de baisser le coût du
travail est pas lié à cette concurrence
des pays de l'est et du sud
réduire un peu la retransmission des
normes européennes on n'est pas obligé
de tout retranscrire donc un véritable
travail à faire au niveau des normes et
puis soutenir l'investissement des
éleveurs qui est qui est extrêmement
lourd
voilà on veut également rappelé que
nicolas sarkozy a très régulièrement des
entretiens avec des avis et beulin
président de la fnsea et qu'en septembre
nous nous mènerons nous ferons des
propositions fortes pour pour le monde
agricole
oui sur le plan agricole la crise est
pas récente
personne dit que le monde agricole va
bien et que c'est d'un coup en 2012
qu'il a vu arriver la nuit on n'est pas
à ce point on sait bien que
il ya des changements de structure
difficile que notre agriculture a besoin
d'être plus compétitive par rapport à
l'agriculture allemande par rapport à
l'agriculture espagnole qu'elle a des
problèmes d'évolution qu'aujourd'hui le
passage progressif d'une agriculture
familiale à une agriculture intensive
d'un nombre d'exploitations plus réduit
c'est quelque chose de compliqué de
complexes et qui se vit mal dans les
zones l'évidence mais nous avons depuis
deux trois ans lydia disais à l'instant
augmenter les charges augmenter la
fiscalité sur le monde rural
pas seulement sur le vendre râle mais
sur le monde rural aussi c'est à dire
que les exploitations agricoles qui
étaient déjà très fragile et qui
subissent l'ensemble des contraintes
supplémentaires sur justement les heures
supplémentaires sur la transmission des
exploitations sur les charges sociales
par rapport à l'emploi etc
ça n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe le ministre de
l'agriculture dit nous avons créé des
cellules d'urgence et de crise dans
chaque département depuis la mi-février
est tous fiers et nous dit de la
mi-février à la fin juin on a distribué
au travers des cellules de crise 23
millions d'euros dead et 23 millions
d'euros des 10/10 lui-même qui a entre
20 et 25 mille exploitations d'élevage
qui peuvent disparaître c'est à dire
qu'en réalité on fait quoi
ils ont dans les 1000 euros aux
exploitations qui sont couvertes de
dettes qui n'arrive plus à vendre un
seul produit à des prix défiant toute
concurrence mais vers le bas
aujourd'hui les exploitations agricoles
ont des prix de vente dans bien des cas
inférieure au coût de revient
c'est à dire que finalement vendre un
kilo de viande leur coûte plus cher si
faisait rien
comment voulez vous que ça fonctionne et
c'est pas l'intervention sur réaliste du
chef de l'état qui dit aux grandes
surfaces
merci de bien vouloir augmenter vos prix
qui change la donne
il faut un vrai plan pour l'agriculture
aujourd'hui la situation est telle qu'il
faut un plan un plan massif de
désendettement des jeunes agriculteurs
pour leur permettre d'investir pour leur
permettre d'aller de l'avant si on ne
descendait pas l'agriculture c'est pas
le saupoudrage de 23 millions d'euros
qui va changer
j'espère que monsieur le foll jeudi va
prendre des engagements plus précis nous
nous serons amenés à faire effectivement
des propositions plus précises dès la
rentrée parlementaire
mais l'agriculture française elle a pas
besoin de la mendicité
voilà elle n'a pas besoin de l'aumône
elle n'a pas besoin qu'on lui jette
trois francs six sous en lui disant
tiens et avec ça traverse la crise elle
a besoin d'un vrai soutien d'un soutien
mental moral financier matériel parce
que l'agriculture française c'est l'un
des fondements de l'identité c'est le
franchement l'indépendance alimentaire
c'est un fondement de l'indépendance
nationale et nos agriculteurs que l'on
critique tant sur bien des sujets sont à
la fois ce qui assure l'indépendance
alimentaire de la france les paysages la
réalité visuelle de ce qu'elles paient
aujourd'hui et si on continue de les
traiter comme des parias de l'économie
française est bien tout ça va
s'effondrer
il est grand temps que le ministre de
l'agriculture se disent c'est pas 23
millions 1 qui peuvent sauver
l'agriculture française quand la france
se vante de pouvoir trouver des
milliards pour la grèce peut être qu'on
peut trouver des vrais moyens pour
l'agriculture française